اين ادتياف اين برونو مارس ولماذا سيلين
ديون خارج التصنيف اعتراضات بالجمله على
غياب رموز فنيه عملاقه في قائمه افضل 200
مطرب عبر التاريخ والتي اصدرتها المجله
الامريكيه رولينكستون لعل ابرز ما فيها ان
كوكب الشرق ام كلثوم حلت في المرتبه
الحاديه والستين ونقول 61 فقط عالميا
اعترض كثيرون على ترتيب مطربين بعينهم
لماذا مايكل جاكسون مثلا مايكل بوب في
المركز السادس والثمانين
عبر تويتر شارك كثيرا من العرب في انتقاد
القائمه لا تمثيل عربيا في القائمه
باستثناء ام كلثوم لكن ترتيبها المتاخر
كان مطار التساؤلات كيف يعقل ان تكون كوكب
الشرق في المرتبه الحاديه والستين وعلى اي
اساس يمكن ان تتقدم عليها ليدي جاجا مثلا
اما جاره القمر فيروز غابت تماما عن
القائمه غاب صوت العرب محمد عبده ولم يذكر
اسم عبد الحليم حافظ العندليب الاسمر
لقد تعض امراه
ولدي يهواها القلب
[موسيقى]
يكن او القمر جراح
عارفين وعيدنا
دارك كبير
[موسيقى]
كنت
بشتاق لك ولا اولا ما رايكم بهذا التصنيف
لافضل مطربي العالم في التاريخ
انه اختياره ام كلثوم ضمن افضل 200 مطرب
او مطربه في العالم
الخبر في حد ذاته خبر سعيد بالنسبه لي لكن
اا سريعا ما همم قعدت افكر لما شفت
الترتيب وان هي رقمها 61 وسط الاعظم حسيت
شويه انه الموضوع لا في بعض
في بعض الظن شويه لتاريخها والمشروعه خاصه
انه حيثيات اختيارها او اختيار ال 200
مطرب كانت قائمه على فكره التاثير العميق
للفنان في و- مشوار الطريق ولو حسبنا كويس
هنلاقي انه من اعظم المشروعات ال-
الغنائيه والموسيقيه في همم في التاريخ
العربي كله
ومن اعظمهم في العالم طبعا المشروع الفني
لام كلثوم يعني
المراه التي تربعت على عرش الغناء لاكثر
من 50 سنه من حياتها اييي منذ العشرينات
وحتى يعني حتى راحلها سنه 75 وهي
الاكثر شهره والاكثر تاثيرا في المشروع
الغنائي العربي فكان من ال- اا من الافضل
يعني ومن المفترض انه ما يكونش فيه بعض
التحيز للامر يعني بانه ام كلثوم تكون في
مكانه متقدمه شويه عن كده
طيب هذا عربيا خلينا نذهب عالميا ونتحدث
في هذه النقطه مع زان هنا في الاستديو زان
اهلا بك معنا اليوم معدوه هذا هذه القائمه
وهذا المقال اعتبروا ان هذا التصنيفات هي
مرتبطه بافضل المطربين وليس بافضل الاصوات
التالي بتعت انه في ناس ظلمه
اليه الترتيب يعني هل هو مساحه الصوت
مثلا جورج مايكل يعني كمان
بدنا نعرف شو وحده المعايير انه بناء على
شو تم ترتيب المغنين بالطريقه اللي ركبونا
الصوت ولكن تاثير هؤلاء المطربين عالميا
بالمرتبه الاولى الثالثه
[موسيقى]